in the Dune universe the gum Jabbar is a
poison needle that can be attached to
one's fingertip the Reverend mother guy
is Helen Mohan called it the high-handed
enemy the most relevant use of it was in
the testing of humanity implemented by
the Bene Gesserit sisterhood the ghom
Jabbar would be placed upon a thimble
and held at the subjects neck
the subjects hand would then be placed
in a box and through a process which the
Reverend mother calls pain by nerve
induction the subjects hand is subjected
to intense pain though the flesh is in
no way harmed you will feel pain in this
hand within the box pain but withdraw
the hand and now touch your neck with my
gum Jabbar the death so swift it's like
the fall of the headsman's ax withdraw
your head and the gum Jabbar takes you
understand what's in the box
pain this is a test to see whether or
not the subjects human awareness is
stronger than their animal instincts
therefore it is indeed a test of
humanity if the subjects awareness of
the gum Jabbar is powerful enough to
endure the sensations of pain coming
from the box then that person was
therefore human and ready to receive
some of the deeper teachings of the vini
Jesuit according to the Reverend Mother
pain is nothing to a human a human can
override any nerve in the body this is
the been a Jesuit mind over body
philosophy which allowed them to acquire
such precise control over their
physiology by performing the test the
bene Jesuits select for the most refined
humans the ones that do not pass are
removed from the genetic eco system by
way of the gum Jabbar ever sifts and
through a screen she asked the tangental
/of her question shocked his mind into a
higher awareness sand through a screen
he nodded
we bene Jesuits if Pete
to find the humans in the beginning of
dune the lady Jessica is offering a Paul
to the Reverend Mother even though she
knows that he could very well die by her
hands she understands however that the
endurance of pain is key to survival
she is exposing Paul to pain as all
parents must eventually do The
Sisterhood intended to create the quiz
sets hadurok so that they could better
guide humanity down the path they felt
was best when this failed rather than
die out after the pain of defeat the
biddy jezzer it evolved because of their
ability to adapt to pain this is why
they test for humanity they only want
those best suited for dealing with pain
the Gong Jabbar makes an appearance in
other places in the dune universe as
well the child's sister of Paul Atreides
Aliyah also uses a gum Jabbar at the end
of dune when she kills the Baron
Vladimir Harkonnen
and his also mention that all the noble
houses possess some sort of gum Jabara
they were used to dispose of rivals and
foes under specific circumstances the
Benin Jesuit test utilizing the gum
Jabbar was mainly reserved for female
students of the Benin Jesuit discipline
Paul Atreides was administered the test
under highly unusual circumstances being
that he was the accumulation of
centuries of deliberate genetic
manipulation by the hands of the many
Jesuit Paul was tested to determine
whether or not he could potentially be a
danger to the Binnie Jesuit sisterhood
or their breeding program clearly the
bene Jesuit sisterhood vastly
overestimated their own ability to
control a potential quiz that's had Iraq
you